and two famous Grandmaster from Germany
I are caught in a ditch and he was
higher rated than me about 70 points and
it plays very aggressively with the
black pieces and this game will show you
if you play if the opponent is playing
overly aggressive with the black pieces
how you can take advantage of it even
though is a very strong and high rate
the opponent and actually I managed to
win this game just about 20 moves with
the white pieces so that so I want to
show you this game so I'm playing with
the white pieces and I play d4 Knight f6
c4 e6 so there is a litter so we'll talk
about opening here because he likes to
play the nimzo-indian defense if you
play Knight c3 here but when you play
Knight f3
he plays d5 and after you play for
example 93 here he likes to play d take
C for Vienna lines and he's very well
prepared in this opening and he has
played against top players in the world
against kramnik amount and he did well
like he managed to draw against them and
he want some games also so it's
basically a authority in this line so
that's why I didn't want to get it I
know some some of these lines as well
but not as well as he knows because he
plays at a very high level so I decided
before the game to surprise him and play
a move that is considered not very
ambitious in the opening but it will get
into a normal position where we just
play we play chess we don't just
memorize like 20 moves of theory
so I played C takes d5 now he can you
can forget about taking on c4 in this
game and it's not going to be able to
get into the the Vienna lines such as if
you take and then why place efore bishop
before and it should be 5 and c5 so it's
a very complex opening and you really
have to know lots of theory here to be
able to get something
the white pieces even if you know the
theory it's not for sure that you're
going to get something so that's why I
played C takes d5 now he has to take
back with a pawn if he takes back with
the Queen it's just it's very bad
you will just play Knight c3 and gain
temple and same as if it takes with a
knight it's a bad move you will play e4
and get the control of the center so he
has to take back with a pawn which he
did
I played Knight c3 and now I play c6
after he played c6 he protected the pawn
on d5 what do you think is the next move
that he is trying to play here let's see
if you know some it's if it says move
again here what's the next move for
black what do you think bishop bishop
before you could play in this position
but you don't really want to take on c3
here because after you take a white will
have the pair of the bishop so it's not
really going to do much bishop before
here but he couldn't play that move here
because here if he plays that particular
move it's bad so he has to play this
move first to protect his Center and
then absolutely so he wants to play
Bishop f5 in this position because his
light square bishop actually this is a
problem in the Queens gambit declined
positions most of the time it's you know
it's a problem for black to activate
this piece because he doesn't have many
squares to go to so that's why I played
Queen c2 here it seems like I'm
developing my Queen bit early instead of
just natural move Bishop g5 which I
think it's very natural but then if I
play Bishop g5 he can play Bishop f5 for
example and now he's going to activate
he's going to activate this Bishop so
that's why I played Queen c2 and now I'm
preventing him from playing Bishop f5 so
it seems like you know the diagonal is
really open for the bishop and he can
move it anywhere but
it's not so easy to develop this bishop
for example if you play a Bishop g4 then
I can play 95 so Bishop g4 it's not good
I will play 95 so and Bishop e6 you
don't really want to put the bishop on
e6 here because it's just very passive
so I played Bishop e7 a normal move now
I develop my bishop he could actually
play g6 here which is another move but
if he does that I was planning to play
Bishop to g5 and now if he plays Bishop
f5 I have a play Queen b3 and now it's
not so easy for him to protect this pawn
normally in this type of positions black
wants to play Queen b6 here when you
attack the pawn with crematory he wants
to play Queen b6 but here he cannot do
that since the knight is going to be
hanging on f6 so he is going to have to
play a move like play a move like b6
which is not really good because now c6
pawn is going to be weak so white is
slightly better here so that's why you
know he didn't play g6 it's a Bishop e7
I play Bishop g5 from opening it does it
doesn't look like it's going to be a
short game it should looks like it's
going to be just a typical Queens gambit
declined positional game where black a
white will try to do a minority attack
on the Queen side so he cancelled
isolate III and now the mainline in this
position he is you know by plays 9b d7
and then rook e8 9 f8 and this is the
typical setup here for black but instead
my opponent decided to play an
aggressive move this is where he starts
to play very aggressive which is not
correct because he didn't finish his
development yet as you can see all these
pieces are not developed and normally
you want to develop the pieces first
before you start thinking about attack
especially it's very very dangerous when
you playing with black because you
playing down a temple so he played 94
activating his night and now you have to
play a very precise move in order to
take advantage of it because if you
don't play this move then the strategy
it shows is going to be fine so why to
play now what's the best move here for
white what do you think obviously the
bishop is hanging and you need to make a
decision what to do with the bishop you
also take your bishop
if you think in order move just until
you can say the move aha Bishop f4 why
do you think Bishop f4 is better than
the natural Bishop takes C 7 absolutely
here it's very important for white to
get the control of the e4 square so if I
take only 7 it's going to be an
inaccuracy because he will just take
with the Queen and he has a protection
on d4 Knight it's very well protected
now and then he will play Bishop f5 97
and complete his development so that's
why I don't want to take only 7 if I
take on the 79 Magnum able to take
advantage of the inaccurate move 94 he
played so I go to Bishop f4 good move
and now I'm threatening to take only 4
and win a pawn so I'm threatening to
take and win a pawn so he has to play he
has to make a move to protect this night
because if he takes on c3 I will just
take back with a pawn and this this
whole idea 94 93 is questionable because
he wasted lot of moves with his Knight
right he played Knight f6 94 Knight c3
he spent 3 moves to capture my net which
only moved once so it lost two temples
and next move I will play Bishop d3
attacking on h7 and after I Castle I
will just play c4 attack the center so
itís white has a very comfortable
position here if he takes on c3 so when
he played 94 I already knew here that
he's not going to take on c3 and now he
also cannot play Bishop f5 I mean he can
play but it's a bad move because after
Bishop d3 now he's going to have a
problem with the e4 Knight here because
now I'm threatening to take and just win
a pawn and if he captures the knight on
c3
I will take on at five first attacking
on h7 and then I'm also threatening to
take the light so it's like is at least
losing the pani probably is to go back
only four then I can just capture he
takes back when you four end you can
give a check here but in this position
since black doesn't have any development
you can image us go kinky too and it's
very safe and this way now you can
connect your rooks okay d1 ok c1 and you
have a very comfortable position so so
you can apply Bishop f5 now what can you
do then what can he do now to try to
keep this knight on e4 yes absolutely he
has to play a5 now now he protected his
Knight only four but if I really
weakened the position of the King in
particular this diagonal and if I square
so I just played Bishop d3 developing my
bishop
I played 97 now let's stop here for a
moment and I want to see if you can find
the best move and a plan here for white
let's spend a few minutes and think and
you can you can let me know what you
think here how should I play in this
position of course I can just play
castle but then if I Castle he plays
let's say Knight d f6 I'm not really
taking advantage of his you know a
little bit premature you know active
play with 94 and f5 so what do you think
I should try to do in this position so I
can take advantage of that and again
remember E for square is very important
right now he has the control of the
square by playing f5 but you weaken the
position a little bit but if I can get
the control of this square then I can
have very good attacking chances also
any ideas yes I probably the 92
following up with that free you could do
that but but then I'm also a little bit
weakening my position too and I'm
spending like two moves trying to move
the night and after f3 he will probably
just 92 for example he will play Knight
to f6
and after f3 he could he could perhaps
just take on the 2 and it's about equal
position is about equal here so I don't
think I have much advantage here what
else I can try to do because remember
that he weakened the position while by
playing f5 try to think of a little bit
more aggressive idea here for white to
prepare an idea to attack
what's the idea behind that move good
you got the right idea but you can
prepare that idea a little bit better
absolutely you play a ch3
you play a ch3 now because when you play
rook G 1 and G 4 right then he can take
and your rook is going to be a little
bit misplaced on g4 like you can move
his knight and discover the attack so
it's not going to be that good so that's
why you want to play h3 ok and now I'm
preparing to play g4 here and once I
play g4 and take on a5 now I will gain
the control of the e4 square which is
very important and I keep my king in the
middle of the board because I can cancel
to the Queen side if I have to and also
I haven't played g4 yet so this move is
also something that he needs to consider
but my main idea now I want to play g4
so now he played g6 protecting on f5 but
I think the better move maybe is just to
play Knight d f6 after g6 is already a
really weakening case position here but
if you place this move then I was
planning to play Knight e5 activating my
knight let's say place Bishop ee6 then I
play f3 attacking the knight he takes
Knight c3 I will take back with a pawn
now I'm threatening to take the pawn on
f5 and after he plays g6 if you were
playing this position why to play what's
the best move here for white
what do you think of course I can just
cancel and have a slightly better
position but I have a stronger move here
absolutely chief or yes chief or very
strong now and if it takes I will take
back with the h-bomb now my age look
it's very active and now I have
threatening to take on g6 and I don't
think he can really defend this position
here so after G for a very strong attack
here and even though my king is in the
middle of the board and we know
according to the principles you
shouldn't really attack but again there
are no hundred percent rules in chess
and there are exceptions like in this
position my King is actually very safe
only one yeah I mean I can I can move it
up to e2 and it will be very safe again
because all my piece are very active and
if you look at the position black
doesn't have any active pieces
so after g4 I will be threatening to
take on a5 and I will be opening up the
position of the black king
so that's why maybe he didn't play this
move Knight gf6 replayed g6 and now he
protected the f5 pawn what should I do
now
this really changed anything should I
change my plan [ __ ] for it's a good
idea to remember when you choose a plan
and if it doesn't change much
you didn't really make a move that
prevented it you kind of stick with a
plan okay you if you think you believe
the plan is a good plan you go with it
okay try not to change the plan in the
middle okay so now I play G for now I'm
threatening to take but he was expecting
me to play this move so he played g5 and
now it's going to get really sharp
there's going to be a lot of variations
here now for example if he plays Knight
d f6 here I'm not planning to capture on
f5 because then he will take capture
with the bishop I will play Knight e5
first preparing to play f3 to move this
strong night and now if you place Bishop
e6 I will play f3 Knight takes c3 and
suddenly this is a transposition to the
previous line that I showed you when he
played Knight d f6 instead of g6 move
and now again we reach the same position
where I have a very active night my
Queen Bishop also very active strong
bishop on f4 and now I will have some
open files on G file or perhaps on H
file and very good position
so that's why yeah if you place nice df6
yeah after 95 again white is much better
here
so he's played g5 attacking my bishop
I played Bishop h2 and now he took again
it's very risky now for black because
his King is really open now
now again white to play let's see if you
can find a best move here because now my
knight is hanging on f3 and if I cannot
just take back with a pawn because he
will just take my knight
so here I had to start calculating
we should take smite it's a possibility
we should take Silas possibility but I
would like to keep my light square
bishop because if you look at the
position he has so many lights course
these light squares are weak so you'll
be nice to keep the light square bishop
for that tack night X night it's better
now again here's couple of options so
we'll look at what he can try to do here
because he can take with the he can take
the e night you can take the F night
with the pawn or you can take with rook
so you can do many different things here
so my opponent played rook takes f3
we'll take a look at that so let's take
a look at some other possibilities
now if he takes back with the pawn I was
planning to play Bishop c4 check now he
has two options to play King g7 or King
h8 if you go sting h8 I will take H
takes g4 and now you can take back on
after with the rook or pawn if he takes
with a pawn a discovery check he takes
and Quint x h7 mate again blocking is
just too weak so now let's take a look
if you place King g7 here it's a better
move I will take again knife he takes
back with a pawn we go check he has to
take check
and check with the look blocks it
queen g6 mate okay so he has to he has
to play rook takes f3 the only move in
this position I take Queen takes e4 now
I'm attacking on the rook and also again
I have pressure on h7 so he plays rook
h3 now what do you do here
you could Castle but here we have an
opportunity to win the rook so you play
Bishop e5 check he takes and we go rook
takes h3 now also threaten to take on h7
so he has to play Knight g6 to stop that
threat and now now we play Castle
queenside King is safe and now
threatening to play rook dh1 and I mean
even though even though black has two
pieces for a rope but I actually have a
pawn also so I will have very strong
centers and position is I think waiting
for white here so next move is look T to
h1 and Bishop d3 if you plays Knight h4
so it's just the position of the
blocking is just weak here so that's why
he didn't play this line so let's take a
look at other possibility he played rook
takes f3 and he can also take back with
a pawn but if he takes back with a pawn
I will play the same move that I did in
the game so I don't want to show you
here because I actually want you to find
this move because to be honest at first
when I went to this I didn't see this
move I was thinking two more kind of
traditional moves that I have here she
not like a normal type of mouse but this
particular move is very strong and I
believe my opponent perhaps
miss this or underestimated how strong
this move is because after the next move
I think white is almost winning big
advantage for white after the next move
it's not so easy because there are so
many things I can try to do here there's
so many night moves I can take for
example on g4 so it's not so easy to
choose which move is the best here for
white
you could do that you could do that but
in this position I'm not sure if it's
going to be as strong because he's not
going to take the night so he will do
maybe perhaps 9f8 now he's solidifying
the position a little bit see that move
actually gives him the break which
normally when you're attacking you don't
want to give a break to your opponent to
solidify his position now he will
solidify a little bit and then now g4
pawn is hanging his bishop is going to
come in interesting move
it's a very interesting move Knight c5
but you have something better because 95
he will maybe play Knight f8 for example
95 he will go 9 f8 92 now when you're
attacking you usually want to go forward
with your pieces no but I mean 92 is a
move but 92 I will he will just take
rook takes h3 but from general
principles when you're attacking this is
looks like it's going to be kind of a
all-out game here why it will sacrifice
some material go for all-out attack so
you don't know if you bring the knight
back to d2 then you're not going to be
able to use this piece you know soon for
the attack so it will be too far away 96
is the right move absolutely but of
course 96 is not a movie we can just
play you have to see exactly what's
behind it but at first I was looking at
some other moves but then when I realize
I have 96 suddenly I just realized I'm
like I'm almost winning here let me show
you some of the lines in fact maybe you
can find it so why this move is so
strong so as mentioned earlier now once
that you move this Knight now I have
this pressure on the diagonal on h7 and
I'm pressing play Bishop takes h3 Bishop
takes h7 so let's see how he can first
defend this idea
first of all if he takes on d6 I will
just play Bishop h7 check and then it's
not so clear where he's going to put his
King and next well I will take a bishop
on d6 so not I also have now two bishops
very powerful attack so this is probably
losing for him so he needs to really
defend somehow on h7 so let's take a
look at the monster well he played nine
f8 that's probably the most natural move
but let's take a look what's going to
happen if he just plays rook takes h3 it
takes the second part now and now is two
pounds up and we still have to prove
where is the compensation here so why to
play and win win force twin
my 25 we could do that but night is
actually very active and if you go night
with five he will maybe go night f8 and
try to protect on h7 absolutely check
now he has to take continued aha Queen
takes rook hi
well it's it it's going to work
if black goes back to g8 it's going to
work because you have a maid but
unfortunately he can go here and see
yeah if I had the light square bishop
then it would have been nice if we'd put
the light square bishop on f7 f v h7 so
I've only made so so that's why I can't
play this move right away but I D is
correct which page seven now first I
weakened the position of the King and
now stick with a plan but how we have to
go for the mate because we sacrifice too
much material now I'm down a piece and a
pawn so now if I give him a break he's
going to consolidate then I will lose
Queen g6 so if he goes to a fade he just
loses the rock if he goes King h8 you I
think already familiar with the idea how
you made in this position right what do
you do yes well yeah I guess there are
two ways to check me but I'm talking
about this Bishop e5 I did that I showed
you a few other lines Bishop f7 check
and you take on h7 mate 937 leads to
also a nice mate because he has to take
and Bishop e5 double checkmate and just
soul yeah yeah so he has to play rook g7
best defense he has so it's actually you
have to really you have to still work
it's not like it's like check checkmate
it's not so what do you do next
Queeny six check King f8 only move and
for a moment it seems like wait we give
a couple of checks and now we don't have
checks and we down a piece he wants to
play Knight f6 next move and then also
trap the Queen so now you really have to
find this move Bishop to e5 good move
now you open up the H file for the rook
to go to and if it takes your bishop
just check and mate but what is he place
Knight f6 attacking on your Queen rook
check correct now he has to keep the
rook here otherwise you have this I
don't know if you notice you also have
this mate here so he has to keep the
rock there so it has to go 9 g8 don't
rush don't rush that's the most natural
move but don't rush the rook takes
Knight check correct deflecting the rook
back has to go back Queen a seven eight
okay so I had to see all this actually
before sacrificing you know before
actually even playing 96 because very
important to have this lines otherwise I
am down material so that's why 96 is
very strong he can't play rook h3 when
we do the over review of the game we
will go with these lines again because I
know it's it's kind it's not simple it's
complicated but now he played 9 f8 it's
another move looks like he just
defending on h7 and now he is also
threatening to take on d6 and
now what do you do here
he wants to take on d6 when a piece also
wants to take on h3
in the next room it's kind of similar
aha we should take search seven very
good yes I played that move and now he
didn't take actually because if it takes
he actually loses immediately so let's
take a look why if it takes
Quin g6 check now he has two options he
has to go King f8 or King h8 if you go
skiing h8 now again I take because I
need to well sorry actually I don't need
to do this now I can just check I just
check and it has to block the check with
the piece he has to put something on f6
could be a rogue Bishop doesn't matter
whatever it does next move is knight of
seven mate so just knight of seven mate
so this loses immediately but he has to
go King f8 and now it's again it's not
so easy because if I take on h7 he takes
my knight so you have to find a really
strong move here
create six check he just goes back to g8
so I have checks but only perpetual so
actually I the kingís well well rock is
guarding it so what can you do here see
when you're attacking usually and let's
say we I'm attacking with two pieces
here right and looks like it's just I
need another piece here right
you're usually that extra piece extra
force you to be able to break through so
you think of what can you do to bring
another piece because you bring another
piece then you're going to have a good
chance here well yeah he suggested he
suggested that move but that just Queen
h6 it just goes back to g8 so so it just
goes here well I could move to I could
you mean take I could do that but that
idea it's more effective when the king
is on h8 it's more effective then here
it's not as effective I mean it's a
problem it's a playable move but there's
something better something that just
wins the game here there should be five
absolutely Bishop e5 now you just simply
make this improving move improve the
position of the bishop and not threaten
checkmate so let's see what he can do to
stop that it seems like he's got so many
pieces the knight Bishop Queen the rook
but he's got four pieces around the key
to defend but actually he can't really
do anything it's that's why I really
like this position here we have the
Bishop e5 because first let's take a
look if he takes the knight he
eliminates the knight now we go Bishop
d6 so I basically made it the only way
to get out of it has to sacrifice the
Queen and I just take the Queen with the
check so this loses now my threat is
Queen g7 he cannot put a minor piece
like a knight or a bishop on f6 because
then he just gets mated
so the only move he has in this position
is rook f6 then I just take again you
cannot take my bishop because then there
is a mate 1 f7 has to take on d6 Bishop
takes e7 check if it takes to the Queen
HG and now I'm threatening to take the
knight 187 so you cannot move it the
only square he can move it to you cannot
protect so you can move it here but okay
Jade checkmate okay
so you cannot do that so yeah it was
very very important to find this move
Bishop e5 because without this move this
whole idea of 96 sacrificing the bishop
wouldn't work out so that's why when I
played Bishop h7 my opponent played King
g7
now well well he just well well he just
see you're just trying to you know you
know survive I mean if he takes the
bishop he just loses right away
King is actually safer on g7 then on h8
here because if you put it on h8 then I
can take hg and then H file is going to
be open - so King is actually safe which
is the best move here at least he's not
losing right away so now I would I need
to bring this bishop into the game right
so and I do that with the temple and you
know temple is very temples very
important check now he defend the block
Bishop f6 and now now I don't have a way
to break through right away so I don't
have anything right away here but I
definitely need my rook in the game
right I can't just attack without the
stroke so I take hey now I'm not even
down any material so before I was down
upon but now I'm not even down any
material here so now he took the pawn
Bishop g4 next move is very important to
find it's a strong move and now the roof
on f3 is misplaced and now I'm thinking
of how I can trap this piece I can do it
right away but in couple of moves you
will see that I trap this rook how I did
that
- one steps up
you could but you leave your bishop
hanging so I actually like the rook on
I mean rook g1 it's it's it may work but
you have something better something it's
forcing basically I'm not giving him
that break that I mentioned when you're
attacking you don't want to give the
opponent a break so if I give a break he
plays Queen d7 and it's a little bit
consolidating here so I don't want to
allow him to play Queen d7 yeah
well the game ended in just four or five
moves basically it's just it that's how
how about his position is here but you
have to find this move yeah but if you
look at the position Knight f5 I treat
my active knight on d6 right for the
bishop I'm still much better but you can
do something better than that Bishop f5
very good because my bishop is not doing
that much here we should did his job
I took his pawn weak in the position of
the King now I would like to trade this
bishop and now his bishop is trapped so
he's forced to take it then he can
defend this bishop so first he took on
e5
now I have a choice I could take on g4
but this way he may play rook takes III
check pawn takes and he takes on d6 even
though I'm up exchange probably winning
but it's not so easy you know to find a
win immediately here so that's why I
didn't want to do that I want to keep my
strong nine so I took D takes e5 and now
you play Queen a5 check
now you have to find if you make a wrong
move actually white loses here now it's
not a very difficult move but you have
to see that he still has the bishop
right here so you can't put the King
here or here because he will just take
and check me so that's why I don't and I
can definitely you don't want to
exchange Queens because you have a very
strong attack and if you do that here
after the exchange you lose a piece here
because he has two pieces attacking on
it so the King iPhone only move and now
if you if he wants to protect his Bishop
the only way for him to do that is to
play Queen before but if it does this
can you find a move that wins this game
immediately a3 excellent oh yeah
sometimes when you're attacking on one
side of the board you also have to see
what is going on the other side of the
board and see that you have a move like
a tree you simply attack the Queen and
now all the squares the Queen can go to
on the fourth-ranked to protect his
Bishop I'm controlling the squares so he
has to move the Queen back and I win his
the bishop and I'm up a piece so this is
very important that I have the movie
three actually because without a tree
then you know I'm probably still winning
but it's at least he can survive for a
little bit so King F 1 now he played
Bishop takes f5 I play Knight f5 check
and now he has only two options he can't
go on King g6 because then I can do a
discovery check and win the rock so he
played king f7
but what if you please King g8 how do
you win if it goes King g8 here
you could do night of seven but 97 but
remember I mentioned that I want to drop
this rule and I have them trapped here
so let's try to drop them because we win
exchange and we still attack absolutely
King g2 and now Luke is trapped I mean
if he takes on a five I just take back
I'm up exchange with a winning attack so
it plays g4 only move I could check on
h6 and win the pawn winning but there is
a better move remember when you see a
good move you look for a better one
absolutely rock edge for now I will take
on g4 with the check and the rook along
with it so that's why I didn't go king
g8 so he played king f7 let's move
number 22 and after my next move he
immediately resigned immediately
resigned so let's see
yeah you could work in g2 which is
winning also in G to G for Andrew cage
for n I mean there are many ways to win
here I mean there are many ways to win
but yes
90s yes you could check but let's try to
trap the rook
Knight to d4 excellent
Knight to d4 excellent yeah very good
yes somebody mentioned 94 in the back
but I guess they weren't so sure so so
94 and now rook is trapped no squares to
go to Luke is trapped so that's why
Grand Master Knight each resigned and
this is the the highest rated player
that I beat in just 23 moves so again
it's almost 2700 player and number one
player in Germany so again I think the
problem in this game for him was he just
played too aggressive in the opening
without development playing 94 f5 and
then playing g5 now we'll do an over
review of this game and also some some
people who came a little bit late we'll
see as well ok so you will be finding
the moves as white and I will play the
moves for black ok so just raise your
hand ok and then I will call you and we
can do a review of this short game ok so
g6
continue yes absolutely
but it's going to get complicated right
g5 now your just start calculating now
he attacked my bishop what should I
retreat this bishop very good move now
he takes and again when you play a
position like this from my experience I
can tell you when there are so many
different possibilities the best thing
for you is not to rush and spend your
time okay if you're playing a normal
game let's say you have an hour hour and
a half for the game spend time here
because if I would have rushed here I
might have played a different move here
so take your time in a positions like
this you have to calculate many
different variations and then realize
which one is the best that the one that
can give you an advantage now what did I
play here Knight X right why is it
better to take with the knight then
Bishop remember see I mentioned this
right why is it better to take with the
night rather than bishop
because why why I want to keep the
Lascaux bishop excellent that's the
that's the that's what you have to say
perfect so you want to make sure you
keep your life's good Bishop here
remember it was very active this bishop
in this game so I can use it as a
tacking force so my bishop is much
stronger here for the attack then
tonight because his light scores are
weak so I want to have a light square
Bishop on the board that's why I took
with the night so now he captured rook
takes f3 and now the surprising very
strong move yes excellent yes we didn't
mention this move because we need the
night if we sacrifice the night we would
have a check but I don't think we can
make him here like it will do here
perhaps we still have some initiative
here but you know we could get a
position like this with a knight on d6
it's much stronger I mean we have some
checks we have Queen g6 but I think
objectively I don't think we have a maid
here you know so that's why it's better
to keep the knight Knight is very strong
on the six it's extremely rare that's
why I didn't see this move right away
when I was planing because you know it's
extremely rare you actually can play a
move like this most of the time it's not
going to be a good idea because either
he is going to take or either you're
just going to end up taking the c8
bishop and I don't want to take the c8
bishop here because this bishop never
moved so I don't want to make so many
moves with my knight one two three four
and just take a bishop I will lose so
many temples by taking a piece that
never moved okay so when I paid 96 not
planning on taking the bishop I just
want to use the square it's very active
score so he played nine f8
like you to tell me again why rook h3 is
losing we looked at this now this is not
the game this is just the sub validation
here how do you break through here
Bishop takes h7 rook takes 8 7 follow it
up check by Quinn yeah sorry we looked
at this yeah but this line doesn't quite
work because he King he escapes from g6
so we go check first if he goes to h8
then Bishop e5 check and made or night
at 7:00 and then Bishop e5 mate so it
goes rook g7 now
yes not yet not yet
Quinn check first move order is very
important very important you know like
in you know it's very important because
combination could you know sometimes it
wouldn't work in most of time you have
to make sure you have the right move
order they should be five now and now
you have rook h8 mate and if he goes
Knight f6 how do we made him don't rush
your queen is under attack - so looks
like wait a minute the Queen is trapped
Knight g8 check very good so he played
that's why he played Knight f8 here now
you still take it absolutely he played
King g7 but why he cannot take here you
remember why he cannot take this trap on
a coin now if he was King h8 we check
with the bishop now he has to block the
check with any pc blocks Knight f7 mate
because that rook is now for example is
pinned you can take it
so 96 not afraid [ __ ] page 7 and if you
place King f8
Bishop absolutely we already import them
or without this move this whole
sacrifice wouldn't work here and now I'm
threatening Queen g7 mate and is in big
trouble
if it takes my night then I take back
with the bishop then King has no scores
to go to the only way to get out of this
to sacrifice the Queen and the only s
two minor pieces it's not a sufficient
compensation for the Queen so he has to
play rook f6 and then we take check if
you take to the king we just take on h7
the knight is hanging and if it's the
Queen now we just take and now it's a
good timing we just take the pawn and
now rook comes in into the game so it's
lost so he played
after the take sacrifice I to keep a
clean g7 continue
we should be 5 check very good Bishop f6
pawn takes pawn takes but now I'm
already thinking ok this rook is awkward
on f3 what can I do to drop it
what can I do drop this through quality
seems like you know he came in but now
he cannot really go back remove its
defender how very good
he takes do I want to win the exchange
and kind of get into complications but I
want to keep the strong knight on these
six keep the strong nitrite takes check
King to f1 don't go to eat your king to
a4 huh if it goes Queen before try to
defend the bishop you remember the quiet
move a tree you always have to look at
the whole board right don't just stay
focus where you're attacking you know
you might be attacking on one side of
the board but it might have a very
strong move on the other side like here
a tree and Queen cannot stay on the 4
track has to go back and you win the
bishop and the game so I played Bishop
fo 5 check Knight xf 5 he played king f7
but if you go scheme g8 this is also
losing because of
not yet 924 was against Kim G to G for
rock h4 excellent take the pawn on g4
with a check and take the rook also so
he's lost so he played king f7 this is
of course losses to discovery check with
the rook and the clicking of seven end
the last move of this game after which
you resigned my to d4 this time not
going forward going back but attacking
the rook and the rook is trapped on f3
and he resigned very good